the clark county school board plans to
consider reopening schools at tomorrow's
meeting
this is secondary students in the washoe
county school district prepared to start
a hybrid schedule that will start next
week
where they attend campus part-time 8
news net reporter kristen drummond shows
us the new consideration
and also how the district compares to
other districts if we're not planning to
reopen right now it may be too late for
this school year
brad mariano tracks reopening plans at
districts nationwide
part of his job as an assistant
professor of education policy
at unlv about 46
of the school large school districts
around the country has have moved past
this phase of distance learning
and are now in some phase of reopening
so that leaves about
54 percent that are still with us in
virtual learning
he not only studies the data but
personally knows the challenges of
distance education
his eight-year-old daughter attends the
clark county school district
she got flustered with a writing
assignment and decided it was better to
kind of lay on the four and quit second
grade than
continue but he supports ccsd starting
to take initiative
documents posted ahead of thursday's
board meeting shows district staff
recommends small groups of students
voluntarily returning to campus how many
students
may depend on the school a plan
originally presented to the board
as a first step when transitioning to
hybrid learning
many urban school systems around the
country started this phase
a few months ago i think there's a lot
of questions rebecca garcia is president
of the nevada parent teacher association
she says several parts of the
recommendation are concerning including
not having a timeline for a return to
class not specifying which grade levels
would return and
not making transportation available are
we actually going to be able to reach
the most vulnerable kids
the kids who need support the most
worries as families wait to see
what happens next kristin drummond 8
news now